roger karoutchi sénateur du groupe l'est
républicain dans les hauts-de-seine
vous serez avec nous tout au long de ce
journal merci d'être avec nous alors
votre réaction à chaud jean castex a été
nommé premier ministre est ce que c'est
un bon tournant pour le quinquennat je
pense que c'est surtout la confirmation
que dans la vème république le président
de la république ne supporte pas que le
promu niçois plus populaire que lui
ou est ce qu'il ya un tournant je veux
dire jean castex avec tous deux les
mérites qui sont les siens ses grandes
compétences aux fonctionnaires d'élu
local maire de prades
mais il n'a pas des convictions
l'orientation politique d'aidé des
prises de position tellement différente
de celle d'edouard philippe n'y a donc
pas de changement de cap à la tête du
gouvernement n'a en revanche je pense
qu'effectivement pour des raisons
diverses et sur des sujets compliqués le
président la république ne souhaite pas
qu'il y est comment dire des réticences
voire des contradictions entre l'elysée
et matignon
il est donc allé chercher quelqu'un jean
castex t au delà de ces immenses mérite
a prouvé pendant toute cette période sur
le dé confirmant qu'il ne voulait pas se
mettre en avant qui ne cherchait pas la
lainière
il était le monsieur déconfinement s'est
jamais lui qui annoncer quoi que ce soit
c'était soit le président la république
soit monsieur véran ministre de la santé
wall premier ministre donc en fait ça
correspond à ce que souhaitait le
président la république en réalité avoir
la main sur l'ensemble des dossiers
alors on verra plutôt avec la
composition du gouvernement
l'entrée ou la sortie d'un certain
nombre de ministres il ya une
réorientation une recoloration écolo une
recoloration plus progressistes en tout
cas le changement de premier ministre
aux pommes un ancien lr remplacé par un
ancien l air alors c'est vrai
l'un plutôt juppéiste l'autre plutôt
sarkozy
c'est pas franchement la révolution de
palais ni le renversement des tables
mais jean castex sera plus en retrait
plus modeste plus plu à la limite plus à
la main du président de la république
que l'été de voir philippe qui était
député maire d une très grande ville qui
avait des forces tu avais une force
politique derrière lui en réalité ce qui
n'est pas le cas d'un de castex est très
appréciée à droite sur ses compétences
techniques sur ses prises de position
passées sur le fait qu'il a été à
l'elysée avec nicolas sarkozy mais qui
n'incarne pas un courant politique
quoi donc je pense qu en fait on est sur
l'aboutissement de la vème république à
savoir un président à un public voit un
premier ministre compétent techniquement
parfait mais pas forcément ayant une
force politique pouvant être une force
politique qui ne crée pas totalement en
accord avec le président alors comme
pompidou giscard d'estaing et bayal
macron a choisi de nommer un quasi
inconnu au gouvernement est ce que c'est
un choix selon vous surtout qu'à un long
seulement un choix volontaire mais c'est
à un choix très clair alors c'est vrai
que depuis deux trois mois depuis que
jean castex et est devenu le monsieur
déconfinement il a eu par définition
beaucoup de rencontres d'entretien que
le président république
je pense que prévu et a dû apprécier
l'intelligence la compétence de jean
castex qu'il eut contesté par personne
mais en même temps il a dû se rendre
compte qu'effectivement par rapport à
edward physique qui depuis quelques mois
10 paris prenait des libertés et avait
dans la loyauté mais avait quand même
parfois des différences d'appréciation
avec le président la république qu'il
exprimait d'ailleurs au parlement moi
j'ai des souvenirs de questions
d'actualité lorsque pas follement et
honda moi d'ailleurs sur un salon de
questions et il y avait des nuances par
rapport aux positions propos du
président la république et les romains
des nuances parce qu' edouard philippe
commencé à un carnet quelque chose qui
politiquement n'était pas exactement le
maquereau nisme
et ça c'était probablement insupportable
ou en tout cas difficilement supportable
pour le président est d'ailleurs je le
reconnais pour le fonctionnement normal
de l'exécutif la cinquième alpes les
coudes président et la clé pu vraiment
le le vrai la vraie clé de voûte et papa
pas le premier mais bon on verra dans la
suite
mais je pense que jean castex sera plus
en retrait elle n'aura pas de
différences d'appréciation avec le
brillant avec le cul selon les disait
jean castex est l'homme de la situation
l'homme du déconfinement réussi sur
quelles problématiques va-t-il être
attendu que veulent les français
aujourd'hui je crains que les français
eux mêmes n'en sache rien ou plus
exactement
les français sont toujours contrairement
à ce qu'on peut imaginer quand on voit
parfois la rue les françaises ont
toujours dans l'inquiétude
y aura-t-il une deuxième vague de
pandémie sera ton re confiné je précise
d'ailleurs que présent avec dit que jean
castex loeb lui déconfinement fin dans
la public dans un interview à ce
quotidien régional n'exclut par
confinement donc je ne sais pas trop
bien
il ya une logique implacable à thiais
mais au-delà de ça je pense que
l'éléphant c'est vrai très attentif à ce
que va faire le gouvernement global sur
la gestion de la pandémie la sortie
réelle la crise les risques deuxième
vague ça c'est le premier élément est le
deuxième élément c'est une évidence
c'est que la crise économique et sociale
aggravée par la pandémie
on ne sait pas encore bien pour on va
sortir on a bien qu le gouvernement
l'état mettre des milliards pour penser
sur le chômage partiel sur soutien aux
entreprises sur la compensation mais
mais ça veut quand même pas dire tout ça
malheureusement ils à prévoir une
explosion du chômage qui va pas y avoir
des faillites des fermetures une crise
économique et sociale extrêmement
lourdes et graves à l'automne donc on va
attendre du gouvernement à la fois la
gestion de la pandémie et le fait de
limiter la casse
dans la crise économique et deux mettre
en place un plan de relance qui puisse
redonner un peu d'espoir un peu de
confiance aux français qui en ce moment
ne savent plus très bien où va le pays
alors là dessus s'ajoutera un petit peu
ce qui s'est passé dans les grandes
villes à savoir la volonté un peu plus
un peu plus de 2 de proximité d'écologie
mais pas le sentiment dans les landes
lille a été aggravée par la pandémie
les gens ont peut être besoin de plus
deux éléments de localisme ont plus
besoin de proximité auront le sentiment
que le mondialisme et la mondialisation
avec tout ce qu'on a vu sur notre
dépendance pour les médicaments notre
dépendance pour un certain nombre
d'éléments de base les gens veulent une
espèce de rapatriement de l'activité au
niveau national voudrait plus de
proximité voudrait plus de d'éléments de
vie qui soit plus naturel ce que l'on a
vécu ces sacs les gens veulent quand on
dit encore inconnue
je sais pas s'il ya plus d'écologistes
yaki à cinq ans ou dix ans et la crise
de la pandémie a clairement appelé les
français à se dire on veut une vie plus
naturel non pas au sens strict du terme
mais on voit bien avec l'apport
technique que l'on ne dépendait trop de
l'étranger de chine bat donc pour les
médicaments ou pour un certain nombre de
sujets donc c'est vrai que tout ça le
gouvernement va devoir le mettre en
place alors soyons clairs et douar sidi
pas commencé à mettre en place
c'est pour ça que je ne comprenais 46
pas la donne justement avec ce nouveau
visage
est ce que le président de la république
emmanuel macron veut donner un nouveau
souffle après l'épidémie du trop vite 19
tous les problèmes économiques qui s'en
sont suivies est ce que c'est une
manière d'apporter un nouveau souffle à
ce gouvernement
ça on va attendre quand même les
premières déclarations de jean castex
est très difficile je ne dis pas ge
s'est pas du tout une critique à son
égard
mais comme ça
à brûle pourpoint non à brûle pourpoint
c'est pas quelqu'un qui vous fait penser
que la table va être renversé que ça va
être maintenant la lui révolution
politique social économique
c'est pas le genre du personnage qui est
quelqu'un d'extrêmement compétent certes
pas très classique si ce qui permettre
au sens de l'administration de la
politique de l'état très classique
vraiment très classique donc je ne vois
pas un souffle tout à fait nouveau
maintenant attendons les premières
déclarations du nouveau premier ministre
et attendant surtout la composition du
gouvernement parce qu'au delà du produit
2010 s'ils rentrent dans ce gouvernement
des gens totalement différent là
peut-être commencera à se dire tiens ça
c'est quelque chose d'un peu plus
particulier par rapport au gouvernement
précédent mais ça faut attendre quelques
heures le temps de voir venir
les nouveaux ministres pour le moment
c'est plus dans la continuité que dans
la rupture
alors après on verra lorsque les choses
sont dures mais ma crainte pour
apprendre ce que le présent à bulles et
nous habituer à des discours des prises
de position en attendent toujours que la
table soit renversé mais où après dans
l'effet concret elles ne l'étaient pas
alors je ne doute absolument pas ça
c'est pas le sujet la compétence de jean
castex qui l'a reconnu à droite comme à
gauche comme quelqu'un d'extrêmement
solide compétents équilibrée y aura un
esprit ouvert un esprit dif
après au niveau politique c'est pas un
changement véritable par rapport à
edouard philippe
ce sera le mot de la fin merci roger
karoutchi d'avoir élevé avec nous je
rappelle que vous êtes sénateur et les
républicains des hauts-de-seine